bill what would you say to an actor
that's in the wonderful position of
being offered paying roles but then
there's that catch there's that sort of
problem of prosperity where all those
people that knew you is the great actor
that could do things for free for the
love of it now know that you're a
working actor and there's a cost this is
probably the most difficult transition
that I've had to go through in the past
year you do work for free when you come
here and because you just want to rack
up imbd credits you work for very low
pay you take as many jobs as you can get
but if you stay here long enough and you
were able to survive you will reach a
point where you have to surrender some
of that control to your representation
and you have to trust your
representation enough so that they say
you're not going to be in this project
you say no to the project you become an
offer actor I have less auditions now it
doesn't mean that I don't have to try it
just means that now my roles come more
through relationships then through cold
auditions than they used to because
people have somewhat of an awareness of
who you are but it's very difficult when
someone comes to you who you've had a
prior relationship with at a very very
low rate and they come to you with the
project and you have to say please speak
to my representation you know I'm glad
that we're friends and I love working
with you but talk to my representation
that's a big step especially if you've
come here as a do-it-yourselfer and
you've worked very hard to get to that
level and then they speak to your
representation and they may call you and
say Karen I can't believe that I'm being
talked to this way I've heard that and
what they mean by I can't believe I'm
being talked to this way is I can't
believe that your representation is
asking for a fair rate of pay and
they'll say things like well it's coming
out of pocket
well everything comes out of pocket you
know on profit this is business and this
is what I do for a living and at some
point and this is the hardest thing for
an actor to do because we're all needy
we're all needy is to say I have a skill
I have a certain set of skills that I
can do on camera I have something I can
bring to your production and I want to
bring it to your production but you have
to pay me to do it just as people have
to pay you to do your job you don't ask
a plumber to work for free and I know
that actors have to work for free but as
soon as you can stop doing that stop
because it's a bad habit and it's not
gonna bode well for your future and your
representation won't like it and when
you reach a certain point you depend on
that representation well what if someone
says to you oh this is a passion project
we're all here out of the love of it and
we're a non-profit and everyone else is
doing it for free and if everyone else
is doing it for free then everyone else
must be rich and I'm not you know I
don't have steaks in the freezer this is
a business there is room for passion but
at some point the movie is going to be
released let's say I want to hire you
and it comes down to an additional
hundred bucks silly example but it comes
down to hundred and you want that
hundred bucks and I'm saying no so we're
going to stop and think is Karen gonna
bring an additional hundred bucks of
value to my project that's ten DVD sales
is it likely that in the world ten human
beings will buy my movie more because
Karen's in it if not you don't need to
be in it but the answer is probably yes
if I approached you in the first place
so both sides on the negotiating table
have to be smart you can't insult the
other person but this is a business and
actors do this for a living it's my
passion but it's also my living I'm a
stock and if a stock gets to a certain
point there's no shareholder that wants
to say well let's lower the value
because then you'll never get back to
the value that you were I know it sounds
cold and hard and even passionless but
if the deal has worked and I actually
get on set I pour my passion into it but
my passion is not for working for free
that's not the way to build a career do
you think people realize that when you
approach someone
or pay and then you try to kind of
retract and say hey is there any way we
could do sort of a barter type of a
thing that that sours it even more I
think so yeah it's just a matter of
respect I've had actors say offer me gas
money at least that at least that it's
just showing respect to the actor yeah I
think so and and you look at the level
that the actor is at to what project
said they worked on recently do they
actually bring value to the project if
they don't fine work for free or don't
be in my movie but if you have actually
approached an actor and made an offer
and then their representation comes back
to you and says that's not enough what
can you do
don't be pissy about it negotiate it's
like any other business I'm buying a car
I'm not gonna pay the sticker price but
you're not gonna let me walk off the lot
for 2 grand either we're gonna go back
and forth back and forth back and forth
and and I have noticed that what seems
to be different in this business at
least on an independent film level is
some people don't want to do the
back-and-forth they don't like the
process of negotiation because they just
want to make the passion project and so
do I but you never get to that unless
you can negotiate again it's looking at
it as a business
so friendships let's say they then come
back to you and say I can't believe your
representation spoke to me like that and
people do how do you handle do I owe
them a favor or not because if I owe
them a favor then I'm gonna call my
representation and say you know I need
to repay this favor can can we work it
out to do this project but if I don't
owe them a favor and they call me and
say your representation has hurt my
feelings I'll say my representation is
not me
and you're not hiring me your friend
you're hiring bill over jr. who is a
commodity that I've spent four years
busting my ass to build up and that's
what that commodity that's what the
current market value of that commodity
is I'm still Billy I'm still your friend
but it's hard to make that separation
sometimes
you